Chris how are you I'm good dan how you
doing I'm going ok I want to play
something from Vlad a debug yesterday
and you tell me you know what exactly is
blah day as the Kings GM saying about
what they did and the culture of the
Sacramento thing so here's a couple of
clips from Vlade Divac the better deal
two days ago then what you got now yep
and then you had a better offer for
cousin or 12 years ago close to those
ages I don't want to go into details I
don't discuss about the process was a
big process for us they deserve better
and I'm in position to try to make it
right way and I really believe this is
the right way to do it chair the crusher
and moving forth ok what was the deal
the better deal that he had two days
prior honestly then I have no idea
because nobody did I've talked to has
suggested there was a better offer what
what what I wanted was a deal with the
Lakers that would send Brandon Ingram
back to Sacramento but the lakers from
what I was told were never willing to
put Angermann to that deal so I don't
know what his better offer action was
moreover it is you know I was just
everything Sacramento does boggles my
mind it really does over the last year
they have rivaled the Knicks but the
most dysfunctional franchise in the NBA
on almost a daily base and for Vlade
Divac to stand up there yesterday and in
a press release suggests that culture
matters and character matters this is
three weeks then after he basically
pledged allegiance to demarcus cousins
in a very public way did he just
discover that character matters on
winning teams he just realized that hey
we need to get a real positive culture
to be able to succeed in the NBA it was
it just they are the gang that can't
shoot straight out there they really are
and Vlade Divac continues to go out
there and publicly stand in
on a v-back Ranadive he's been
suggesting for the last 24 hours that
this was all him but he decided now with
the time to trade DeMarcus Cousins that
is completely false that is completely a
lie this has been entirely feedback
ranadive he has been trying he being
Vlade Divac has been trying to trade
DeMarcus Cousins for at least six months
if not longer and defects been standing
in the way it was only because with the
repeated acts of immaturity over the
last month that diva finally got out of
the way and they're able to make this
deal for DeMarcus Cousins what do you
think about the pelicans is they move
forward with Anthony Davidson DeMarcus
Cousins it's a calculated risk on the
part of the pelicans because if you're
the GM Dell Demps you probably know that
if you don't make the playoffs you're
going to be out of a job and if you're
the head coach alvin gentry you know
that if Dell Demps out of a job chances
are you're going to be out of a job so
the 2017 first-round pick is a risk it
could turn out to be a good player and
what is a very good draft but you don't
have options here you've got to try to
pair cousins and Anthony Davis together
and see if you can find magic I mean
look on paper Dan Alvin Gentry coaching
a plodding big man who won't run past
half court at the time does not make a
lot of sense but what they can do is
just hope that they find they strike
lightning in a bottle and these two guys
who are arguably the most talented
players at their respective positions
can find a way to play well together and
everything will just click easy former
Celtics ball boys Chris Mannix who joins
us on the program okay well I was going
to lead into the Celtics here and are
they going to trade for Jimmy Butler
like yeah right because my ball boy
experience will be able to lend some he
says the likelihood that the Celtics
bring and Jimmy Butler is what this
one's going to go all the way down to
about 255 p.m. on thursday dan because
the Bulls right now have to weigh a
couple of things number one they have to
figure out if over the next three years
well two years really because that's how
long Jimmy has left on his contract a
player option on that third year are
they going to be really competitive
and they build around Jimmy over the
next two years because that's a reason
to keep him also they have to decide
that Jimmy and Fred Hoiberg can coexist
Fred Hoiberg was the hand-picked choice
of gar forman and John Paxson they
didn't interview anybody else after they
fired Tom Thibodeau so they're not
getting rid of Fred they have to figure
out if those two guys can co-exist and I
don't think they're going to make a call
on that until right up until the
deadline because they're going to see
what bought how deep Boston will go into
that treasure trove of assets the game
father now I think Boston will throw
that 2017 Nets pic into this into the
pot there I think they don't want to
they'd rather go 2018 but I think they
have to they'll go 2017 the question for
Boston I think will come down to will
they put Jalen Brown their third overall
pick in that deal as well they love
Jalen Brown and often they think he has
superstar written all over him they
don't want to deal Jalen Brown they'd
probably prefer to throw a Marcus smart
into that mix but that's what it might
come down to Dan will they throw Jalen
brown in and will the Bulls accept an
offer that doesn't include him Magic
Johnson's role with the Lakers what is
going to change here and when when do
you see change happening with the Lakers
that's a dramatic pause yeah it is Chris
and we lost him I blame reebok John a
diva I think Mannix's pronunciation game
is spot on this morning the charts and
we'll see if Mario can relocate Chris
Mannix there you know that was good
radio if you're listening in your car
and you heard him pause you're thinking
oh my god there's something really going
to happen with magic Johnson yeah Paul
and you really nailed the Magic Johnson
set up in question I did I did crush
that do we have Chris Mannix like Chris
you've got me you got me okay that was
really really dramatic pause on your
part so Magic Johnson's role with the
Lakers means what I wish I had something
more oppression to tell you they're dead
but the reality is it's not going to
happen this year it might not happen to
start of next year and I think there's
going to be a civil war within the
organization before magic takes over at
all I don't think Jim Buss is going to
willingly see complete control to Magic
Johnson I've been going to see an
all-out fight within the Lakers to do it
and you know what I tend to agree with
Jim Buss and with Mitch Kupchak if they
fight for this team what have we just
seen in New York dan you hand control to
a basketball operations to a basketball
novice at least in that position and you
can't expect real results the only way
Magic Johnson is going to be successful
is if he goes out and spends millions of
dollars on the best staff humanly
possible exactly what Phil Jackson did
not do in New York City that's the only
way putting Magic Johnson in a position
of power there is not going to work
unless you assemble the best basketball
staff around it to the calves or
Warriors make a move this week not this
week the cavs and warriors neither one
of these teams have assets to make a
deal they're trying but nobody out there
wants their stuff they don't have draft
picks to deal either what the only way
the cavs and warriors get better before
march first is at that buyout deadline
either you're going to see a run of
veterans you might see rajon rondo you
might see Andrew Bogut there could be a
few players that could be impact off the
bench guys for you know for the cavs and
warriors to fight over and that's what's
going to be on LeBron we've talked a lot
in about lebron's frustration with that
Cavs front office how he just doesn't
feel like they're doing enough to
upgrade that roster if these guys break
free LeBron's can have to put his best
John Calipari hat on and recruit these
guys because it's not going to be that
easy you know these guys say a Bogut
breaks free is he really going to want
to go to the Cavaliers and play 10 or 15
minutes per game or go to another team
where he could play 20 to 25 minutes and
earn himself his next contract so it's
going to be difficult but that's where
the Cavs get better with LeBron recruits
guys to have them come play for
Cleveland Chris great stuff is always
thanks for joining us then there's a
possibility possibility that Ricky Rubio
could wind up in New York and if that
happens my life is made will you share
an apartment with Ricky Rubio if he does
get traded to the next
I would happily sublet my apartment live
at a hotel you live in a hostel you live
on the street where ya anyway so this
would be Rubio for Derrick Rose it's not
really likes to it quite yet but the
bowls of I'm sorry yet the wolves have
been pretty clear that they they want to
hand the reins over to Chris done
eventually Rubio's got two years left in
this contract rose only one that's
that's the only way would they would
make this deals if they feel they can
just transition to Chris done easily
next year and Claire roses number off
the cap can they send Rubio back to
Spain um I mean I go with him but I
don't think that's the plan right now
thank you Chris I can that's Chris
Mannix from the vertical the vertical
trade deadline show Thursday to 24
eastern on the verticals come the Dan
Patrick show weekday morning on audience
[Music]